démonstrations de danses et cocktails à
gogo le tout dans une ambiance de soi
reid
les créateurs de l'application with
sportes n'ont pas fait les choses à
moitié pour son lancement
yannick il est l'un des fondateurs de
l'entreprise explique comment ça marche
c'est une application mobile qui me
permettrait de trouver un partenaire
sportif et malheureusement je n'ai rien
trouvé
et c'est de ce moment là je me suis dit
je vais créer applications sportives tu
vas me permettent de trouver un
partenaire sportif autour de moi à côté
de chez moi qu'on pratique et peu
importe le sport que je veux dans un
premier temps with portes sera testé en
ile de france et proposera tous les
types de sports pour lesquels il y aura
des recherches de partenaires ce soir là
toute l'assemblée a téléchargé l'appli
est même commencé à l'utiliser report
cela que mon téléphone vers l'emploi
banco de demain je vais tuer pour un
sport d'ailleurs demain il ya une course
à 16h d'ailleurs je serai son usage
reste gratuit pour les particuliers
en revanche côté professionnel du sport
il faut conclure un partenariat avec
l'application pour pouvoir y figurer
salle de sports association du club
sportif semble s'intéresser cheka forme
on recherche beaucoup les des
particuliers comme ça qu'ils nous aident
à justement avoir plus de clients chez
nous donc ça peut nous rapporter
vraiment beaucoup de beaucoup de
potentiel les entrepreneurs vise 10
mille utilisateurs d'ici à trois mois
dans le département mais aussi ailleurs
en france
une fois ce palier atteint il espère
toucher d'autres clients comme les
seniors